today I present to you the medley of
every single song on my album in order
let's go a lot of people on the
Internet's like writing songs about
weird things and one thing that can
cause upset is the hardship that rhyming
branes rhyming words like things and
bringers is pretty freakin easy but
finding a rhyme for internets can make a
man feel queasy one two three four five
six seven eight spots on my face too
much acne to embrace the person behind
them sits on my back with head bright
white skeleton black and much too much
an awkward place to pop them I am you
you are me together
they make a perfect charlie and when I'm
feeling down
we know that de always be around dopa me
dopamine
you're my favorite animal but I'm biased
I guess because you look quite a bit
like me and when I stand to and my you I
can't help but best for your mannerisms
tell me with glee I'm not really in love
with anyone
but sometimes I like to pretend in the
bad hailey Jehovah is my girlfriend she
lives all the way over in America and we
don't share the same political views but
as far as hypothetical girlfriends go
she'll do this is my math lousy
formality are already forgiven come
please don't regret let's watch you did
to day this is a song about but not a
very good one I don't know to tell you
about heartbreak but I know it's there
and you can avoid it by listening to
your head which is just what I'm done
and it isn't perfect but when I've done
the instead bread bread what does Santa
Claus do for Halloween oh wow what does
Santa Claus - hello
[Music]
this is a song about a song cuz this is
the me that I like to be charisma quick
wit and charm but that side of me rarely
likes to be in the face now personally I
don't really like selling things here on
my youtube channel it makes me feel a
bit awkward but I feel a bit more
comfortable talking about this because
it was once I started posting solo songs
on my youtube channel that I got
comments from people saying you should
make an album and so I did I made an
album for you all of the songs in the
album are proper studio recordings of
all your old favorites and plus some new
never-before-heard
tracks the actual real physical CD thing
is currently available for pre-order on
dftba.com and it will be coming out on
December the 1st thank you for
supporting my music and by extension me
and I'll stop selling you stuff now
alright you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
tell on Charlie just need to press the
switch